Hi, this is Dr.
Kaladner, we're going
to be discussing
eating disorders.
Our session objectives
are to compare
and contrast
feeding and eating
disorders as per
the DSM edition 5
classification, to
discuss the common
behavioral and
psychological features
of these eating
disorders, to review
the signs and symptoms,
risk factors, and
some subtle exam
findings that may
support the diagnosis,
to utilize BMI
calculations to aid
in the diagnosis of
eating disorders,
to identify common
consequences and
complications, and to explain
some appropriate
treatment options.
So read through
the case and think
about it as we go
through this talk.
There's a second case.
Eating disorders
are characterized
by disturbances in
body image, body
weight, and or
eating patterns.
This is a list of
the common eating
disorders that are
acknowledged by the DSM-5.
Both males and
females are affected
but more often
females between
the ages of 12
and 25 years old.
This is a screening tool.
It be used effectively by
primary care physicians.
As you can see, it's
very simple and quick.
This is another
screening tool
called the Eating
Aptitude Test.
It's the most widely
used screening measure.
It's a self-reported
26-item questionnaire,
so this one takes
a little longer.
Let's discuss
anorexia nervosa.
The DSM diagnosis
requires the low body
weight, an intense
fear of weight gain,
and a distorted
body image for at
least three months.
Although the BMI is
used to determine low
body weight, keep in
mind it is not a very
accurate assessment
of obesity as it does
not take into effect
body fat percentage.
There There are
two subtypes
of anorexia nervosa.
One is caloric
restriction,
which includes
excessive exercise.
The other subtype is
binging and purging.
The median age of onset
for anorexia nervosa
is 18 years old and
women are three times
more likely than men
to develop this. There
are a plethora of
medical complications
and a very high
mortality risk.
There's a list
of the most
common medical symptoms.
They include amenorrhea,
fatigue,
weakness,
constipation.
These are the most
common signs that you
could see on your
physical examination.
Complications develop
as a result of
starvation-induced
fat and carbohydrate
catabolism, leading
to organ atrophy.
There are numerous
cardiovascular
complications, most
notably arrhythmia,
which can be
fatal, of course.
Neurologic
complications include
cerebral atrophy,
enlarged ventricles,
cognitive impairment,
and seizures.
Endocrine
complications include
hypothalamic dysfunction,
osteoporosis,
stress fractures,
hypercortisolemia,
and hypoglycemia.
Reproductive
complications include
amenorrhea and
erectile dysfunction. A
rare but potentially
fatal complication is
called refeeding
syndrome and it's caused
by too rapidly increasing
caloric intake.
The key to success
in treating
this is to
identify it early.
Most common causes
of death in anorexia
nervosa are suicide
and tachyarrhythmia.
Treatment revolves
around nutritional
rehabilitation
and psychotherapy.
Bulimia nervosa occurs
when there are
episodes of binge
eating followed
by compensatory
behavior to prevent
weight gain.
To be diagnosed, this
must occur weekly
for at least three
months, and it
is unfortunately
often missed because
patients maintain
a normal weight.
Inappropriate
compensatory
behaviors
include vomiting,
fasting,
overuse of laxatives,
and excessive exercising.
Vengeating entails
eating very large
quantities of food
in a very small time
frame. patients
report that they feel
out of control and
they won't stop
eating until they
are painfully full.
I'm in a five times
more likely than
men to develop
bulimia nervosa
median age of onset
is 18 years old.
Signs that you
can see on the
examination include
tachycardia,
hypotension,
erosion of dental
enamel from
the recurrent
emesis, which is what
is being shown
on this slide.
Medical
complications include
dehydration, hypokalemia,
menstrual irregularities,
and Mallory
-Weiss syndrome.
Once again, treatment
revolves around
nutritional rehabilitation
and psychotherapy,
but this time
there is also
some effective
pharmacotherapy.
the first line
pharmacotherapy for bulimia
nervosa is the
SSRI fluoxetine if
fluoxetine is not
tolerated or effective
other SSRIs can be
tried if they are not
effective or
tolerated tricyclic
antidepressants such
as amitriptyline and
nortriptyline can be
tried as well let's
discuss binge eating
binge eating is
characterized by recurrent
binge eating episodes
during which a
patient feels a loss
of control and marked
distress over the
overeating unlike bulimia
nervosa binge eating
episodes are not
followed by purging
excessive exercise or
fasting as a result
binge eaters are
usually overweight make
the diagnosis of binge
eating three of the
following habits
must be true eating
more rapidly than
normal eating until
uncomfortably full eating
large amounts of food
when you're not hungry
eating alone and
feeling disgusted over
the eating episodes
must occur weekly for
three months there
must be no compensatory
behavior binge
eating is the most
prevalent eating disorder
with a median age
of onset of 21 and
women again are more
affected than men,
this time only two
times more affected.
Vengeitas are at
higher risk for chronic
pain, diabetes,
hypertension, and anxiety.
The mainstay of
treatment, of course,
is cognitive
behavioral therapy.
CBT consists of
using thought
exercises or
real experiences
to facilitate
symptom reduction
and improve function.
It also includes
education,
relaxation techniques,
coping skills
training and stress
management It is used
for many psychiatric
illnesses and all
eating disorders
Avoidant restrictive
food intake
disorder occurs
primarily in children
But can persist
into adulthood
Nutritional needs
are not met due
to the eating
disorder, leading to
poor growth,
failure to gain
weight, and nutritional
deficiencies.
Supplemental feedings,
either enteral or
oral, are required to
provide adequate intake.
There is often impaired
psychosocial
functioning. This
disease cannot
be as a result of
lack of food or
cultural practice.
In this disorder,
body image is not
distorted, and it
cannot be caused
by any physical or
mental disorder.
PICA.
Usually, PICA onset,
usually, but not
always, during
childhood. It
may be a clinical
manifestation of iron
deficiency amnemia.
It can be normal and
harmless, like in
a child that eats
crayons or Play-Doh.
Compulsively eating
these substances,
however, is not
normal, and once the
child is old enough
to understand the
consequences, they
should stop eating
the non-nutritional
food substances.
PICA can be diagnosed
if the patient
is eating non-food,
non-nutritional
substances, for
at least a month,
and often we do
not make this
diagnosis before
the age of two.
It can be seen
in women during
pregnancy, patients
with autism,
and patients with
schizophrenia.
Treatment consists of
behavioral therapy.
There are no medications
that have been
shown to be effective
in treating PICA.
So we have a 25
-year-old Caucasian
female presenting
for her 30-week
OB visit for a
routine follow-up.
And she tells you
she's been craving and
eating things like chalk
and dirt, and she's
been feeling this way
for at least six weeks.
So what's your
diagnosis if
you all said PICA?
Rumination Disorder.
In healthy children,
this disorder
usually appears
between the ages
of 3 months and
12 months. It can
be episodic or
occur continuously.
The diagnosis can
be made when there's
repeated regurgitation
of food for at least a
month that is not due
to a medical condition
such as GERD or pyloric
stenosis. It tends
to occur within 30
minutes of every meal.
treatment is the
in the form of
diaphragmatic
breathing chewing gum
after meals can
also be helpful it's
our second case nine
-month-old african
-american male presents
for his well child exam
his mother's concerned
because he's always
chewing something
she's found chewed up
food in his mouth it's
been occurring for two
months. He has no
medical problems, this
child have, and the
nation is where.
Thank you for your
attention. I hope
this was helpful,
and if you have
any questions or
need to contact me,
my email is acoladn
at nyit.edu.